اهلا بكم قبل ان نبدا النشره ننتقل الى
السودان و كلمه لرئيس مجلس السيادي عبد
الفتاح البرهان
يحييكم وعبركم بنحيي كل افراد القوات
المسلحه المنتشرين في بقاع السودان
وفي كل منطقه
السودان وبيحموا اهل السودان
احنا بنحييون ابو الليل نحن وانتم كلنا
قضيتنا واحده قضيتنا الوطن
وحمايه شعبه وحمايه ارضه دي قضيتنا زايد
فيها
ولا عندنا اي كلام في كل زول دي قضيتو
احنا بنقول لهم
ربنا
في كل مكان
اخواننا المرابطين اذا كانوا في الشركه
وفي الغريب او في الجنوب بيدوا نفس
الرساله اللي انتم كلكم اديتوها وهتقدوها
ونحنا اديناها وهنظل حاملين لهذه الرساله
وهذه الامانه
نحن طبعا
في القوات المسلحه في السنين الماضيه دي
عملنا عمل كله يخدم مصلحه القوات المسلحه
ويخدم مصلحه التحول ان احنا كلنا بنعيشه
من 2019 تحول اللي هبه من اجل الشعب
السوداني عشان كذا نحن بنوعد الشعب
السوداني ان احنا في صفه
وكل حاجه تحول دون تحقيق مطلوعاته نحن
نضيف معاه مع الشعب السوداني في انه ينال
مبتغاه وينال ما خرج من اجله من اجل تغيير
حقيقي
من اجل تغيير حقيقي تغيير ما مصطنع تغيير
ما فيه اي جهه كسبانه غير هذا الشعب
والشباب السودانيين اللي طلعوا ضحوا نحنا
كلنا شايفين انه مو عارفين نوم نحن نقول
نحن معاكم ونحنا سند ليكون لكن كل شيء يتم
الطرق الصحيحه
اللي بره الامان نحن في الجيش ما قاعدين
ساكت في السنين الماضي
القوات ونجهزها بكل ما يمكن ان يعينه في
انها تنفذ
تحسين البيئه
انه يؤدي وقادر انه يشتغل بدون ما يكون
عنده حاجه شاغله باله بدون ما يكون عنده
اي تفكير في انه واولاده خلاهم وين بيخلو
الجنوب يتعالجوا كيف وبيشربوا جنوا وغازات
ولابس شنو مسلح بجنوب وقاتل الجنوب قاتل
الجنوب
عشان كده بدينا بدينا في اصلاح رقبتنا في
اصلاح مؤسستنا العسكريه من التنظيم من فوق
لغايه اخر جندي
منهج الدخول لي الكليه الحربيه كله صلحناه
الناس اللي بيسمعوا الاصلاح بتاع الممثل
العسكريه ما يخافوا نحن بنصلحه بالطريقه
اللي انت مكينه وتقويها وتخليها هي وحده
فعلا جيش سوداني حقيقي بيحمي السودان
وبيدافع السودان
مع نسمح للجهه تعبث بالقوات المسلحه
ده كلام نحنا بنقول لكم
قاعدين
حق الشعب السوداني والشعب السوداني يستعمل
هذه البلد لذلك
ما في تسويه ثنائيه نحن صحيح في واحده في
ورقه قدمت نحنا عملنا عليه ابو لحظات
الجيش
كرمته تحفظ جيش وحدته تحفظ للجيش
الاستقلالته جيشنا مستغل وموحد وقوي البرد
ما بتيجي
اذا ما دخل وسوس اذا ما دخلوا سوس من بعض
السياسيين
السياسيين دخلوا في شارع القوات المسلحه
ونتكلم بصراحه
نحن الشراكه الفضيناه في 25 اكتوبر مع
الحريه والتغيير لن دخلت جوه الجيش
عشان كده احنا فضينا معهم الشراكه ونحنا
نتكلم في الجيش عدوه بالنسبه لنا اذا كان
الاسلاميين والله الشيوعيين والله البعثين
مجموعه تحاول تتدخل في هذا الجيش هي عدو
بالنسبه لنا ولا حاجه
نحن شايفين
ومتابعين بعض الناس احسن
ارجوكم من عندنا مثلا
في 25 اكتوبر
نحنا ثاني الكلام ده بقول الله يعين الذهب
حزرنا جهات معينه نازل
نحنا ما عندنا ولاء ولا عندنا انتماء
انتماءنا للجيش ده انا دخلنا الكليه
الحربيه سنه 80 الكلام اللي قال اخونا نحن
عشناوه سنه 80 في سرير رابعه كان معنا
المرحوم كان الفكي كافي من لقوه المرحوم
عبد الحميد حسن نافع من سنجه معنا اخونا
علي هذا هارون من نيابه معانا اخونا عبد
الحميد عبد الرحمن عبد الرحمن
خالد حسن مختار من الجزيره او من البطانه
معانا اخونا عبد القادر عبد القادر من 24
قرش كنا كلنا السودان ساكنين في عنبر واحد
ما بنعرف
يجمعنا اشكال كذا تجمعنا القوات المسلحه
عشان كده هذه الصفه وهذه القوميه نحن بدنا
قوميه القوات المسلحه هي القوميه
السودانيه
ولان لهذه القوات لن يتبدل وحنضحي عشانه
نحن
سنمضي الى ما يحقق استقرار السودان
سنمضي الى ما يحقق وحده السودان
نحن صحيح تم التفاهمات بيننا وبين بعض
اخواننا في قيادات الحريه والتغيير نحن
فيهم هذه الروح
والتزموا قدامنا انهم ما بيعملوا للجسم
معين هم بيعملوا من اجل السودان
احنا معاكم سواء والتزموا قدامنا انه ماذا
يرجعوا ثاني
وترجع دا كلام ولينا ما في حزب كان مشارك
في الفتره السابقه احنا شغل السودان كلهم
نحب نكرر دعوتنا اليوم
البلد ما تضيعوا البلد في هذا النزاع
النزاع الغير محدود ما عنده احد كله زين
متمسك برايه
عشان كده في رؤيا واحده نقعد فيها شريحه
نصلحها اذا فيها عوجه نعديلها اذا فيها
حاجه مو مزبوطه لكن كونه نتمنع نقول الله
نمشي ونحنا نحنا ما جاتنا الورقه وعدلناها
القوى السياسيه وتعدله عشان بلدنا يا
جماعه
احنا لينا ثلاثه سنين ماشيين متراجعين
انظروا الى الشوارعنا انظروا الى مصانعنا
انظروا الى مزارعنا كلها اثار ضرر واصابه
خراب كله ناتج من طب متروس كله اخوانه
سياسيه
ما بيغلبنا لكن احنا دارين توافق دارين
توافق محمي محمي ونحنك قوات مسلحه زي ما
اخونا ما قال اخونا حضره الصول دايرين
مدنيه يحرس الجيش ده ما فيها ثاني بتحريزه
ونحن نكون غائمين عليها وحارسنها
كلكم انتم ثاني انا بمشي محمد عثمان بيمشي
وانتم قاعدين
سوداني انتهى عشان كده احنا دافع عن هذا
الجيش نحميهم
نحن ماشي
جيده نزعل لانه توافق مع كل جيراننا مع
اخواننا في جنوب السودان نزل عشان نحل
مشكله مع اخواننا الاثيوبيين اول حاجه
احنا بنهنيهم قال ان هم حصل بينهم وبين
جبهه توافق نحن نقول لهم ده عمل يصوف في
مصلحتهم السودان لانه نحن متضررين من كله
نزاع في اي وحده وسندعم هذا الدفاع ايضا
سنفعى لانه نساوي مشكلتنا معهم بالطرق
السلميه اذا كانت الحدود وبسب النهضه
السودان مش عارف بتاعه الحدود كلها نحن ما
في فرق بيننا وبينه ان احنا كلنا سعد واحد
لذلك انه علاقتنا مع دول الاقليم مع دول
الجوار تتبع علاقه ملتزمه علاقه بتاعه
منفعه متبادله وعلاقه والتوتر
بلد ويحافظ عليها نحن بنحييكم وبنقول لكم
تاكدوا تماما انه نحن وانتم سوا كلنا يد
واحده ضد عدو هذا السودان نحنا وانتم كلنا
يد واحده ضد عدوي القوات المسلحه اي زول
بيبي شرق القوات المسلحه
جديده جدا
دي البوصله حقتنا في علاقتنا مع القوى
السياسيه مع القوه المتبعيه عشان كده
المره اللي فاتحزرنا الناس وحذرنا
الاسلاميه لانه بدو ينخروا وبده يتدخلوا
في هذه الجيش يقولون امشوا بعيد ما عندكم
طريقه تاني تيجوا تدخلوا ولا ترجعوا
تركبوا ظهر الجيش عشان تحكم وما في ما في
جهه الجيش الجيش
ماشا الدغري التزمت نحن كلنا نحميها
احنا عندنا عهود وعندنا مواسير بن راعيها
وبنحفظها دعاهدنا معاكم واحد انا مع الشعب
السوداني ان نحن نمضي في ما يحقق له امنوا
استغراره نحن الحكومه الجايه هذه متوقع
انها تكون الحكومه من المستغلين الغير
منتمين الاحزاب ده كلامنا بنقول طوالي قال
له والله بلد نزل هذا تمشي ومرحبتنا
الانتقاليه تنجح ما تجينا حساب راجع ثاني
لتحكم ما ندخل في نفس المحافظاتك دخلنا
فيها زمان نحن الورقه قلبي نمشي فيها
ونبقى فيها هذه ما على شان جاء معينه لا
يقحت معينه دي للسودان عشان تاخديم
السودان
احنا بنحييكم وبنشود على ايديكم واحد واحد
ونقول نحن معكم ونحن فيكم نحن لو ما
بنلاقيه في الموقف ده ولا ابن نجيزات
هذه الدنيا كان زمان نكون انتصرنا
لكن الحمد لله
بس عايزه زي زي القوات المسلحه هذا الزي
هو شرف بين لينا نحن بدنا نرتديه لانه مثل
وحده السودان بيمثل ع العمود الفقري
والقلب النابض اللي منه بيضخ الدم في
شرايين السودان المختلفه دي كله مكان هسه
الان اللوحه اللي قدامنا دي لويس
نحن جيش نحن جيش فقط تحيه لكم تحيه للشعب
السوداني بارك الله فيكم والسلام عليكم
ورحمه الله وبركاته